one of the tips that I shared on Tick
Tock or Instagram reels was just
renaming your audio all of my audio
always says freelance Friday podcast or
Latasha james.com podcast or something
similar so that when people are seeing
those little sound bites and they are
going viral people are seeing okay this
person's a podcaster let me go check
that out and I do hear anecdotally that
people do that a lot that's a great tip
and to break that down that's where
usually it's a song If you use a song
but when it's original audio it might
just say original audio and you can
actually rename it and then get a little
brand pump to actually put your brand
name in there and all those little touch
points are what make up a brand